hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game between the starfish 8
and alpha 0 at this time alpha zero has
the black pieces since always said you
wanted not all of you but many of you
said that you wanted to see a game that
alpha played with the black pieces but I
think we already shown we have already
shown two games for alpha play with the
black pieces from this match and also I
already mentioned that it's not about
who won this match alpha one this match
very convincingly and they also tested
the alpha against the a version of
stockfish that was still being developed
so i guess at the time this was played
that was towfish 9 and alpha zero want
that entire match as well with similar
results that alpha won the match against
dogfish 8 so iiii do have to repeat this
it's not about who won but how how
enjoyable the games are and really such
a human approach to the games that we
can at least gain something from them
watching the game between two engines is
very often just a dry calculation and
the humans are pretty much helpless
spectators there you can't really
understand anything that's going on it's
hard to understand what's going on on
here but at least we can try and also
those who maybe use a twitter or
instagram might have heard that i have
received my books on josé raúl
capablanca there we have it these are
actually three books in one the all
three written by Kappa Blanc on my chest
career a premier of chess and there you
can see chess fundamentals so a pretty
big book but we will be using all three
of them in our kappa blanka series and
also i received this one it's by the
famous chess historian Edward winter as
you can see a compendium of games notes
articles correspondence illustrations
and other rare was that archival
materials on the Cuban chess genius Jose
raúl capablanca
so definitely a good read but I still
have to decide what which games we're
gonna show which tournaments will be
included in the combo Blanca saga so I'm
gonna start with it tomorrow and then
we'll see we'll see how it goes now but
getting back to this game alpha has the
black pieces and this time we will have
the Leningrad variation of the Dutch
defense so something even humans use
very very rarely
but it will be a very enjoyable game so
let's see how stock which opens start
which plays d4 but this is also one of
the games that uses the opening opening
positions from the TCC 2016 now it's ok
f5 we have the Dodger defense
let me just return these books here ok
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 g3 and g6 now
both function alpha prepared to be in
care to do light square bishop and the
dark square Bishop Bishop g2 Bishop g7 I
will castles castles and c4 now we go
into the main main Leningrad a variation
of the Dodge defense these 6 nights 2 C
3 C 6 we have looked to be one it's
always useful to get this rook out of
this a1 square as the bishop when the
position opens up you never know when
that might happen you don't want the
rook to be there and also you were
preparing further expansion on the Queen
side we have a 5 blocking B for Queen to
b3 and now comes Knight to a6 at some
point that this night will come to c7
and then from there perhaps a six or
maybe d5 here we have rook to d1 and h6
and there is there are a couple of games
in the databases that have reached this
exact same position and there are some
of the games featured III our one game
featured c5 with a discover to check
that game white loss but here alpha goes
for Bishop the story stuff which goes
for Bishop to e3 so as of this moment we
have a completely new game on our hands
and okay rook to b8 developing the rook
also alpha does the same we don't want
the rook on a8 when the position opens
up we have rook b2 c1
it's interesting you might think why
first play rugby one and then rook c1
why not immediately develop the Bishop
to e3 and immediately go rook a to C one
instead of this seemingly wasted tempo
but as we did use the positions from the
TCC 2016 maybe maybe that's the reason
so hard to say but okay Bishop to d7 are
often out develops the bishop and now
comes the c5 with check King to h7 and
now Knight to a4 so you can see is
dopefish grabbed a lot of space here on
the Queen side stockfish control
the b6 square of course you cannot push
b5 at any point as seek after some v6
I'm Poisson which would be played so how
will alpha respond to this nice
expansion I will nice to see seven now
alpha has possibilities because c5 check
was played now as you did to grab much
more space you can draw b6 now but
you've lost control of the d5 square and
also of the be v square so here the
knight on c7 can go at some point even
to b5 or perhaps even d5 we have Bishop
to d2 and now comes Bishop to e6
attacking story screen on b3 Queen back
to c2 and now comes Knight C to D 5 and
here this Knight is now an excellent
piece the pawn be F pawn already being
on f5 and the knight on f6 control efore
so it's very unlikely that white will be
able to push efore to breakthrough and
that way the knight on d5 is very safe
there the C pawn is already on c5 so you
cannot kick it away
we have b3 now comes look back to a8
alpha now wants to control the a 5-pound
with the rook so now the Queen no longer
has to keep an eye at the point now
alpha will transfer the Queen over to
the Queen side which Queen e8 g5 and
Queen to h5 we have Bishop to e1 now
comes Queen to e8 as planned
III and g5 now alpha now prepares to
bring the Queen over to the to the King
side and you can see stockfish now
really has some nice expansion in the
center of the control of the Queen side
is more than obvious but now you when
you see alphas plan that the queen is
coming all the way to h5 and that all of
these points are ready to be pushed and
now you are thinking what is the knight
really doing on a4 and what are the
Queen and the rook is doing here not not
all that much it would seem but okay
Knights to D to buy stock fish are
preparing to bring the knight over to C
for that to challenge the d6 for but
also maybe maybe at some point to go to
be 620 to h5 by alpha and now comes the
ship to f3
attacking the alphas Queen g4 pushing
the bishop back we have Bishop to e2 so
if at any point Queen to h3 comes then
Bishop to f1 will also be a possibility
King to h8 now you don't want to
dispense to be a problem at some point
you might want to add some at some
variations maybe sacrificing the night
and going Bishop d5 to control this
square will be possible so you don't
want this Queen captures on a5 to be a
nuisance sorry about that at any point
so King to h8 on pinning and now comes
Knights the c4s planned
we have Knight to e4 and here comes h4 a
very nice move because capturing on h3
on person is not possible if you capture
then of course you lose the Queen so you
do have a lot of options here or what do
you play Bible with black you could try
a night before to attack the Queen and
go for some play on the Queen side but
alpha plays a really really a beautiful
move here we have Knight to g5 and not
capturing the knight would would really
just be pointless you don't want a long
night to h3 check or even Knight to f3
check where white will have to give up
the very strong light square bishop so
here a stockfish simply decided to
capture the night h capture son g5 h
chapter son g5 and now what do you do
here there are a lot of threats for
black like rook f6 to 2 H 6 maybe with a
nice Queen to h1 checkmate so you do
have to be very careful with what you do
with white if something f3 was played
here but you might think ok why open up
the position why not like Bishop to f1
maybe the bishop can come to g2 and help
out with the defense this way well here
black would have some very very nice
resources like f4 immediately black
would threaten to open up the position
and then after Queen t4f captors and g3f
captures in g3 and now even Knight to f4
and here it would be it would be very
very hard for whites to make a move you
cannot capture the knight would either
pawn if you capture the knight then
Bishop to d5 he'll will win the game you
have to move the Queen and after the
Queen moves then Queen to h1 king of two
and now you are getting checkmate
checkmate it here
so it would be a very very difficult to
position for black for white to handle
after this Knight to f4 stockfish
doesn't think this is playable for white
and so doesn't go for it instead we have
f3g captures on f3 and now Bishop to f1
here stockfish prepares rook to d2 and
then the Queen rook battery will be used
either when the screen or or at least a
repel blacks attack here we have f4
again a very nice move if you try rook
to f6 here immediately
I would this idea then the the thing we
just mentioned simply wins you play rock
to h2 white the defense and we'll we'll
have a better position from there then
on so after Bishop to F 1 we have f4
immediately trying to bust open the
position rook to d2 now threatening rook
to h2 to win the Queen but now F
captures on e3 a wonderful move by alpha
we're now rook to h2 does not work it
really complicates things
f2 check comes and then after King to h1
Queen captures on h2 a nice Queen
sacrifice King captures and now look to
f6 preparing roof to h6 you do have to
make some room for your king so King to
g3 will not be possible
rook to h6 check King to g3 and now you
will capture anyone bring the Queen into
the game and after rook captures you
will bring the other look to f8 you will
have complete control of the H file
complete control of the F file the two
bishops the Knights at the pollen III
our white will not be able to survive
this way to the long the King and g3 so
stockfish doesn't go for rook to h2
rather he decides for a different plan
first Knight captures on e3 and ok
Knight captures on e3 now you've taken
care of the two connected pass pawns but
only now rook to h2 and now here alpha
finds a very very nice sequence of moves
that takes this game into an endgame
that alpha has very high hopes of
winning here I feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only move that
allows alpha to continue playing this
game as of course now white is
threatening to capture the Queen with
Czech you can capture here but then you
lose the Queen will check so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find alphas move the 1 alpha plant as
usual I will give you a couple of
seconds but you know you can pause the
video so it can be even half an hour for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know you are you
play like alpha zero and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show now
alpha played Bishop to h3 now this
blocks the rooks attack to the Queen and
the threat is a knight captures on c2
here white will lose the Queen so what
do you do well as the bishop and rook
are both attacking the bishop starfish
simply captures it rook captures on h3
but now the Queen can capture on h3
Queen capture so we have Bishop captures
on h3 and now comes Knight captures on
c2 rook captures on c2 and now comes
Bishop captures on d4 this comes with
check and you now have to block a check
you cannot move the King because f2 is
coming the pawn would be supported by
the bishop and by the rook so we have
Bishop here but should capture skin
captures this is all for stand now pink
the g7 and this is what alpha saw but
the calculation goes much further
because here alpha has two rooks against
a rook a bishop and the night so
basically a bishop in the night are of
course much stronger than a rook but you
also have to take the position into
consideration that's I mean that's the
only thing you have to take into
consideration and that's something alpha
really excels at we have nice to be six
attacking the rook rook moves rook a to
the 8th and now comes Luke the c3 here
stop which attacks the f3 pawn which is
a very strong pass pawn but here is how
alpha untangles rook 2h8 attacking the
bishop bishop to a c6 and now comes
rogue to h6 again attacking the bishop
on e6 rook to e3 now defending the
bishop and now comes Luke to f8 so by a
nice series of moves attacking the
bishop the f3 pawn is not protected you
cannot capture it as the bishop is
hanging here we have Knight to d7 r up
to H to check King moves and now comes
Luke to e2 again a very nice move by
alpha because now there's no time to
capture the rook and f8 because rook
captures on e3 and you can save both the
knight and the bishop
you will lose at least one to one of
those after the rope moves you will have
to play something and then it's simply a
winning endgame for four alpha so here
after Luke - e - we have rook captures
any - pawn captures the width check King
captures and now comes Luke to h8 so
this is the most likely the position
alpha of course found everything that
was played was forced because every if
anything else was played it would only a
favored alpha so this is normal 43 but
we can we can imagine at that point and
move 30 where Bishop to h3 was played so
from this position this is that was most
likely the position 13 moves ahead that
alpha saw that we would be having this
endgame after rook to h8 and here alpha
saw okay
you do have a knight and the bishop for
my rook but the position is not all that
clear I mean the a pond and the g5 pawn
are on dark squares or light square
bishop is not really gonna be of much
use here on the other hand how are you
going to attack the b7 pawn that's
basically the base of the pawn chain the
e7 pawn is also on a dark square you're
not gonna be able to attack it the King
can always defend it if the knight moves
so basically to capture the b7 point
your knight would have to either be here
and it's very unlikely it's going to
ever ever come there or it would have to
be on a 5 here but how do you attack the
a5 phone also not not at all clear so
okay pink the d3 stock which improves
the position of the King and now comes
Luke to h6 attacks stoppage Bishop
Bishop to g4 and now comes d5 now even
taking the c-4 square from the night so
you cannot attack the a 5-pound even
from c4 we have nice the e5 we have e 6
now so far it is a target the rook is
protecting it but the King will approach
the position soon and then the rook will
again be able to be activated nice to be
7 again it's very hard for for either
the knight or the bishop to attack any
point here but at least now you're
preventing the King from coming to f6
King f7 we have King to e3 and now comes
Luke to h1 now the rook will
be transferred over to the Queen side
and the Queen's iPhones will become
targets and it will be nano it will not
be easy to defend them the strip to f3
attacks the route rook to e1 check Kings
to d2 and now roof to a-1 I will brush
up to d1 and now comes King to e7 first
attacking the knight Knight to e5 and
now King f6 attacking the knight again
Knight to g4 and now King to f5 the King
makes use of the night being attacked to
improve its position nice to h6 check
King to e4 Knight to f7 attacking the g5
phone but now g4 we have night the d6
check King to d4 and now a for the
Queen's headphones are now protected but
now comes Luke 2:8 to with check King
moves and now comes King captures on c5
we have knife captor son b7 with check
King to b6 defending the pawn on e5 also
attacking the knight Knights the d8
attacking the e6 pawn but now comes rope
to g2 Knight captures on e6 rook
captures on g3 now creating a past g4
pawn king to f2 and now rook the c3 we
have Bishop captures on g4 rook captures
unbe 3 and I strayed off Russia back to
be one attacking the rook and now comes
Luke to be for King to f3 and here after
rook to e4 this is most 65 it was in
this position that stockfish resigned
the game or rather it it failed to make
a move you still have of course a bishop
and the night against the rook but black
is up two points which is already huge
compensation and it will be it will be
very easy to win this pawn at at any
point here it's simply worn by force
after we make a move the knight is under
attack let's see one Knight g5 you
attack the Bishop rook to e1 then comes
Bishop to see - now you attack it again
rip the c1
Bishop to d3 now you go rook to e1 you
attack the pawn now Bishop defends it
the bishop to see to rook - a - you
attack the bishop bishop moves and now
you go rook to d2 and now you can no
longer go Bishop to b3 to defend the
pawn because rook the d3 check would
pick up the Bishop Bishop to e2 and here
after rook to be four there are no
or squares of where you can defend the
pawn from as the rook is controlling d1
so here you would win that pawn as well
and then with 3/3 passed pawns and the
rookie would be easily you would be able
to easily defeat a king Bishop and the
night so yeah again a very nice game by
alpha zero using the de Leningrad the
Dutch and really again I'll always plays
this these games where you can like to
tell a story about this entire game from
from how the knight entered the game
after c5 check was played then the d5
square was weakened alpha then used the
d5 square with the Knight d4 square
cannot be taken away from black you
cannot push e4 and then after alpha
consolidated on the Queen side brought
to the Queen all all the way over to the
to the King side and started attacking
and then after a couple of more
preparing moves played oops sorry
play tonight the Nights to g5 and well
from there it was just one one beautiful
attack here after Knight to g5 you don't
have to capture it and then well you can
see that it's not not at all clear it's
a very complicated position but there's
so much potential for black here and the
the white position is pretty much
concentrated solely on the Queen side
it's very hard very hard to defend here
so again again we can use to at least
get some ideas when we play our own
games and that is why alphas games are
are so important for the chess world and
are of such significance so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
don't know if I will be starting the
Capablanca saga tomorrow maybe will
we're gonna check up on the sound way
sit this tournament and then we'll see
how much it will take me to prepare it
as we do have the the world blitz and
rapid championship starting very soon so
we might even do the couple Blanca saga
after that but we might start with some
games before before starting in the
world blitz and rapid championship sure
that's the game I really do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank the
David Hanny
martin raphson a carmen maura slim Amuro
and david Sherman ski for a contribution
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video see our thing called
for watching and I will see soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and yeah enjoy the rest of your
Friday thank you all and I'll see you
soon